[Music]
everyone around me they feel connected
to something connected to something no
it's so exciting to see they come
together it is exciting to see you come
together and I think I have sort of
stuck my head in the sand a little bit
because I worked so hard on it as it
everybody in I know I want to see it
when it's when it's ready you know I
want to see it when Rupert's ready to
show it to me and so I'm still kind of I
kept myself in like a bubble so you
haven't seen the trailer see the trailer
the trailer and what's that like for you
watching the trailer because even the
trailer it's just awesome the trailer is
awesome I was really blown away by the
opening I'm going in what do fans have
to look forward to seeing you in this
role the fans it may have been a little
skeptical with the casting but after
seeing this man I have no doubt I don't
know I'm skeptical of the casting myself
I you know I hope that fans go on you
know this journey of self-discovery with
this character and or you know taking
away into this world the world that
record so painstakingly created for them
you know there's a lot of great kind of
reference to visual references for the
fans that I think hopefully will have
them like standing and cheering so
fingers crossed we'll see
[Music]
you